[Music]
too bad we can't stay baby get out on
Eddie Murphy reference absolutely I mean
I eat Murphy is talking about the
difference between how a white family
and a black family would react in a
haunted house
I've watched you doubled watching
poltergeist last month I got a question
why don't white people just lead a house
when there's a ghost in the house in a
me real hard a ghost told them to get
out of the house why people stayed in
there some of the best bits of all time
it's one of the best bits of all time so
yeah I'm hit get out is Jordan's
directorial debut and he wanted to make
sure it hit the right notes in today's
social climate the story came from this
the this period we were in in the Obama
administration when we were in this this
post-racial lie on race is over we got a
black president let's not talk about it
anymore there was a situation that did
kind of spark a piece of this which
where I was dating a white girl and I
had to ask that question like if we're
gonna meet your parents they know I'm
black and she was like no so how long is
this thing gonna this thing hello dad
and then going and meeting the parents
and I don't know she told him where she
didn't but there was there was no
reaction and that in itself was this
creepy moment I'm like okay well then
what's going on here that to me was like
that's a perfect situation a perfect
thing to give a protagonist of a horror
movie because the my favorite horror
movies it's like there's always a
question am i imagining this so this
this was about sort of identifying these
little these hints and these little
subtle reminders that you know you know
any any black person in America is
consistently reminded that race is real
[Music]